good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the planning committee including
those watching online
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door to the right
of myself
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
you do okay thank you I would advise
that speakers using the microphones are
picked up by cameras recording the
meeting members of the public in the
public Gallery behind the speakers may
be picked up by those cameras and have
their image captured
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting
also I urge anyone filming the
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children present thank you
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber
whilst this meeting is in progress
I have the following members who wish to
speak under Council Council procedure
rule 20.1 item 4A is councilor Dawson
and councilor fellows and item 4E
councilor Whitehead
would any other members who wish to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
please announce now
no thank you
the following applications have been
reserved for public speaking item 4A
land between 310 and 316 Canterbury Road
birchington item 4D 122 northdown Road
Margate and item 4E British Heart
Foundation
113-117 High Street
I have apologies from councilor rizeki
substituted by councilor Wright and
apologies from councilor Paul Moore do I
have any other apologies
or substitutions no
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you
item agenda item three do members agree
that minutes of planning committee
meeting held on the 14th of June 2023 be
approved as a correct record can I have
a proposal please
councilor Auburn proposed Anna seconder
councilor ratigan
thank you
any site visits
will take place for committee members on
the morning of Friday the 4th of August
the planning application will now
outline a point of information regarding
agenda item 4A thank you chair
um on agenda for item 4A which is the
land between 310 and 316 Canterbury Road
condition 18 is proposed to be added to
the recommendation for approval to
confirm that the proposed access located
would be located and approved through
this outline application the condition
would read the vehicular access to be
provided to the site should be from
Canterbury Road only in the location as
shown on the illustrative site plan
numbered
a1625-09 revision P4 and prior to the
first occupation of the site bollards
should be erected on the boundary with
millro adjacent to a raised table to
prevent any vehicle vehicular access
onto Mill Road from within the
application site the ground for that
condition is in the interest of Highway
Safety and to prioritize pedestrian
cyclists on the public right-of-way and
the recommendation is updated to include
this condition thank you
thank you
um so a gender item 4A land between 310
and 316 Canterbury Road birchington
speaking against the application is Mr
Craig Solly you have three minutes
thank you chairman our speakers are
local resident who has two planning
applications back inside to my property
this has been the first to be determined
by this committee
honestly there's been some questions
which has never been answered on this
site the site is not in the local plan
and apply an application for 1600 houses
under sp16 which borders the site
no comment has been made by Council in
the many consultations of the local plan
it's examination or adoption I did apply
for the land to be listed as local green
space under the local plan consultation
in 2017 for which no comment was made
and there's also a bigger need in my
opinion for allotments
the site is also raised at the All
Saints Church PCC meetings many years
ago for which the church was never
consulted with the community and
certainly not to the neighbors such as
myself
under Matthew chapter 22 it is said love
your neighbor as yourself clearly the
diocese is all out and love to neighbors
and the community certainly with our
proposals to close two churches in the
area with an increase of congregation
planned and no affordable housing in the
provision
this application is not fully understood
the lack of information is shown
I'm not also informed in respect to the
parish council's neighborhood plan for
which has been dragged thoroughly
through Council to adopt this
application should bear some weight on
the compliance of the neighborhood plan
but also to SP 16 for which there is a
master plan to build houses it is stated
as policy
it is also not clear what design codes
have followed and how it sits between
one of the oldest passages in
birchington Mill Rowe with a history
going back to 1700s being stated as a
site of the former Hudson's Mill with an
her number
there is no mention of Heritage Assets
in this application and they're set in
we don't quite know if the path which is
currently on the site and where that now
leads as well as intersecting with Pro
tm32 the master plan of sp16 includes a
transport assessment in which Footwear
and cycleway connections are to be
considered this directly affects this
application's proposal at 316 Canterbury
Road there appears to be a path to be
planned but it has no reference to this
in the application and therefore me
raises security issues given access to
the rear of my property
in terms of Highways it appears that the
a28 is going to be a local distributor
out but not a district distributor out
so in terms of Junction spacing this may
be classified as incorrect
it is clear that this road is at or
Beyond capacity and so there's a major
archery for traffic to Fan it the issues
of parking is also a problem given its
location and will promote more parking
on the a28 the location is also not in a
good place for traffic accidents and
it's proximity to other Road Junctions
it is also appearing not to be
contributing to the local plan Road
funding
there appears to be a predetermined a
predetermination on site given that
there's 1600 houses planned under sp16
however it should be clear that this is
not approved as yet and therefore any
statement upon issues as Farmland should
be preserved and protected and it's
incred and it's incorrect to State
monoculture farming has happened
this is the first grain field site under
the local plan in birchington which has
been lost to Housing Development
contrary to many local views the local
plan was also told to give certain
protection and it's very clear this does
not do this it promotes more Greenfield
lands for housing and for that and for
many reasons this application should be
refused thank you
thank you
um speaking on to council rule
2.20.1 is councilor Emma Dawson you have
three minutes
thank you madam chair
um so let's gauge the moral compass of
this application a nine dwelling
cul-de-sac development on a grade one
agricultural land lands not allocated in
our adopted local plan a development
that won't support social housing A
disruption to an already congested
Canterbury Road and no consideration for
Refuge collection Logistics these
dwellings are in addition to the already
planned 1600 homes and as we know the
algorithm's calculation for the housing
quotas proved to be faulty and that
those calculations do not correlate with
housing need
is the elephant in the room and we
urgently need government revision to
adopt a plan which was specifically
tailored to our unique position situated
in a peninsula therefore my decision to
speak against this application is
because we need to adopt a common sense
plan to stop over development thank you
thank you and also speaking under
Council rule 20.1 is councilor Phil
fellows do you have three minutes yeah
thank you chair I'm speaking this
evening as the ward councilor so where
shall I start
um as we've heard first and foremost
This Land Is Not allocated in our
adopted local plan the local plan was
supposed to offer protection against
these type of speculative applications
so now it seems we're faced when
opportunist opportunistic application
for development on grade one
agricultural Farmland which is currently
farmed as we speak in the report from
offices it states basically that because
the land is adjacent to a strategic site
SB 16 in the local plan that it can be
developed alongside that site but after
studying the indicative master plan from
the developers of sp16 it's clear that
the adjacent fields are not going to be
developed as this is an area of
archaeological interest houses will not
be built on it so this is a complete red
herring and I will add in fact chair
um yesterday I had a meeting with the
land Agents from sp16 and they actually
said that they disregarded this site
because it was totally disconnected from
their plan if officers feel that this is
the case then it should be decided
alongside the much larger application
for 1600 houses on the sp16 site clearly
that then would go over the above
numbers of units allocated for the local
plan for birchington
also there are no guarantees that this
strategic site adjacent will ever be
developed the application for strategic
site sp16 has not been passed current
economical factors have slowed down the
housing need and has changed all
developers outlooks there's also a
current suspended full Council motion to
pause all large applications in thanet
to prove this application this evening
we'll open the floodgates for further
applications on any agricultural land
that is not in the local plan but is
adjacent to strategic site sp16 which
stretches all around one side of
birchington also there would appears to
be no consideration for the parish
council's objections or any
consideration for the emerging
neighborhood plan
so onto the application itself number
points I must point out if members
haven't read the report the new access
onto Canterbury Road is plainly
unacceptable it's very dangerous onto a
very busy accident black spot up to 18
or more Vehicles trying to access the
main road at this point in the Russia is
clearly impermissible there's also
nowhere for bin Lloyds to turn around on
collection Day within the site bin
Lloyds will have to collect from the
main road a bin Lorry stop in to collect
nine bins could take five or ten minutes
and this will cause chaos and to block
Canterbury Road for any period of time
in the rush hour early morning is crazy
bearing in mind 16 other 100 other homes
are planned in this vicinity there's
also a public right-of-way running
through the site no protections have
been offered in the application for that
KCC have expressed their concerns
clearly in the report in fact the KCC
report should really give you enough
reasons to refuse this this evening
chair this is plainly over development
it's clear for us all to see from this
report I think the church who owned the
site really had to rethink this
development just because they have no
use for the site does not mean we should
just build houses on it a local history
buff told me years ago there used to be
allotments on this site so if the church
have no use for this site then maybe the
Christian thing to do is to hand it over
to the parish and return it to
allotments that is a much better use for
this site especially in the current
climate members you need to refuse
permission for this that's the correct
decision this evening thank you Chad
thank you I will now hand over to the
principal planning officer to outline
the report
thank you chair this is the application
site outlanding red here so this is
Canterbury Road
um to the bottom of the slide and you
can see Mill row
um running along the center of the side
that were connecting to the center of
the site
um and you can just see two um other
roads uh King Edward Road here and
quicks View Road here so in terms of the
highway Point consideration has been
given to the the location of the access
in relation to these two um existing
accesses onto Canterbury Road
so just for members to
um sort of understand the context of
where this site is located in terms of
the local plan allocations and the
application site is located in this
location here if you can see the um the
pointer of my my mouse here so the
dotted red line is
um the Strategic allocated site for um
housing as a result of this being part
of the local plan allocation the urban
boundary
has changed so the urban boundaries now
follows the outline of the Strategic
site so the dotted red line here is now
the outline of the urban area so the
site itself Now lies within the urban
area
with the area that you can see here
that's shaded green this is Countryside
to the left of the slide and on the
right hand side here
um but this actual site itself is is a
unique site in that it's not allocated
for anything but it's also in the urban
area
this is just a closer view of that so
you can see the Strategic allocation
runs around the site so the actual
application site is this area here so
it's not the full width of the space
this part here forms part of the
Strategic allocation and this bit here
is the application site that's being
considered
um tonight
so this is just some aerial views of the
site so this is the application site in
this area here and you can see it's
currently a space a green space between
existing and built development you can
see existing houses a front onto Country
Road either side of the space
and you can see that it is in
agricultural use
the white line that you see running
along the slide here is the public
right-of-way
um so that is is also for consideration
it extends through the agricultural site
and into Mill row and continues along
millro
this is just a close-up view of the site
so again the application site is in this
location here
um again you can see the public right
away running along Mill Road running
along
um here and again you can just see in
terms of pattern of development and
properties that front onto Canterbury
Road on the left hand side and on the
right hand side you can see there's
quite a variety in terms of the pattern
of development so some properties front
onto Canterbury Road some are side on
and then you can see some small pockets
of of development around Mill Road and
coming off Mill Road to the north here
this again just another view just so you
can see the site so again the
application site runs in this location
here so in terms of neighboring
properties that would be affected
there's the properties either side in
Canterbury Road number 310 and 316 and
then you can see a group of three
properties in this location here and
then a new property has recently been
structured in this corner here so you'll
see some photos of that in a moment and
you can also see there's existing
Hedgerow running along the eastern
boundary of the field but at the moment
there's no other
um demarcation between the application
site and the rest of agricultural site
at the moment
and then just another view from this
angle again just showing um the
neighboring properties and Mill row and
again you can see the agricultural land
and the Hedge boundary and Again
Properties in in Country Road and then
this view is just a wider view so you
can see it in in the context of of uh
other development within birchington so
this area does fall within a landscape
character area and part of the
consideration of that is is the main
character of the landscape character
area is is mainly open space and Views
towards
um the sea so you can see that in the
distance there are there is existing
development in this location and this
area here again is part of the Strategic
allocation around the application site
so these are now some photos I'm going
to show you running from Country Road
and then through the sign into Milroy so
this is in Canterbury Road looking
towards the application site and so you
can see that um it's currently farmed
um
and then this view is looking towards
number um 310 so it's a bungalow to the
right hand side with a small
um Conservatory lean to that extends up
to the boundary
and you can just a closer view just to
show that there's obscure glazed Windows
within that side view so this is the the
actual boundary of of the application
site and then this is looking towards
number 316 um a semi-attached two-story
property so the application site again
isn't actually extending up to this
boundary because there is a small gap
between this property and the
application site so
um it's probably approximately here I
guess there would be a gap between the
application site and number 316.
and this is now a still in country road
again 316 is on the right hand side here
and it's just showing the the starter
properties within Canterbury Road so to
the West the majority do appear to be
two-story and semi-detached properties
um and then you can see the the petrol
station on the left-hand side as well
and then this is now a bit further back
so the application site is in this
location here again just for context you
can see number 316 is this location here
so the application is is sites is to the
right of that the Bungalow number 310 is
in this location and then you can see
there's different style of neighboring
properties further down the road with
these properties
um located uh perpendicular to the
Canterbury roads you can see that not
everything is is fronting onto the road
there's different style layout of
properties in terms of considering the
pattern of development of the area and
then just another view again of that
area so again you can see those
properties the Bungalows on the left
hand side here and this is just looking
further to the east of Canterbury Road
so now going into the application site
this is the application site looking
back towards Canterbury Road with 316 on
the right here and 310 on the left you
can see the existing Hedgerow that runs
along the boundary
and sorry this is just for context so
now we're walking along the right hand
side here you're now going to see these
properties in this location here so
we're now at the point of the public
right-of-way so this is Mill Rowe
and this is where it connects with the
application site you can see the sign
showing the footpath location so you
probably right away extends along here
and then into the application site and
this is the other side so this is a
public right-of-way extending through
the site so you can see that when it's
being formed it doesn't appear to have a
very easy access through on the public
right of the way at the moment
um
and then there again that's the public
right-of-way location at the moment
so these are the three properties
adjacent to the eastern boundary of the
site
um
you can see in terms of the scale their
two story properties
um their rear Renovations are quite
close to the rear boundary but there's
still quite a good distance and I'll
show you the plan that shows distances
um later on
and then again just another view of
those three properties so all of their
rear windows face towards the
application site
and now heading towards the rear of the
site I'm just going to show you the um
the recently constructed property that's
in this far corner
so heading towards that far corner so
the application
boundaries on the right hand side here
this tree we understand to not be within
the application site and within
um the neighboring site
and here you can see this is the newly
constructive property in the far corner
and then again this is this is the
boundary run along here and again that
neighboring property so the windows of
this elevation again face into the
application site
and now this is again looking back
towards Canterbury Road so again the
Eastern boundaries on the left hand side
and again just just a view of the site
so now we're going to head into Mill row
and I'm going to show you the style of
properties along there so this is now in
Mill row so the application site is in
the distance here so this is the
boundary of the application site with
the public right-of-way that extends
across here and you can see the
properties in Mill row different style
properties two-story dwellings again
um brick construction again the
application site is at the end of this
road so again you can see some
properties are set back with some open
frontages some properties front straight
onto the road quite a few terrorist
units but all two-story and height
and then just again another view looking
now towards the Eastern end of Mill Road
so again just the style of properties
that exist so there's a range of
terrorists and so many detached
properties
um and there's no one clear um building
line along here so we'll quite um sort
of set back or set forward depending on
what side of the road is and then this
is just the Eastern end of Mill Road
Again looking back towards the
application sites the application site
would be right at the end of this road
so just to now show you the plan so the
application is in outline form only it's
for nine houses and so all that's being
considered is whether the site can
accommodate nine houses and the access
into the site and that's the only thing
for consideration through this
application the rest would be reserved
for future applications so this
application is supported by an
initiative site plan so it is showing
how the nine units could be accommodated
on the site and how they could be
achieved without compromising the the
couch of the area or any living
conditions but we're not actually
approving the layout or any design or
any scale at this point so this was the
originally submitted layout plan for the
development
um concern was initially raised from
Highway so the main the main
consideration is the access point so the
access was shown in this location here
onto Canterbury Road and concern was
raised from KCC highways in the
proximity of this access to quex View
Road within in this location here and
they required a 30 meter distance
between the Junctions so this this
access was considered unacceptable so an
amended plan has been submitted which is
this plan here which shows the access
moved further west into the site to
create that 30 meter distance to the
junction with quex View Road
highways are now happy with the location
of this access visibility speed of 2.4
meters by 40
um three meters can be achieved from
this access point and therefore highways
consider this to be a safe access I have
gone back to KCC because there has been
some concerns raised about um with some
consensus of potential crash data and
concerns of the actual capacity of the
road
um highways have advised that they
considered there to be adequate capacity
within the road they've said that at the
moment there's 15 000 Vehicles a day
that use the a28 and that the proposals
will generate approximately 40 vehicle
movements per day which is a 0.27
increase and in their view that that
increase will not result in a severe
impact to highway safety in terms of the
crash data that has been supplied by a
local resident they've looked into the
crash data and all of
um they said that they would usually
only look at three to five years from
the point of submission as to as to any
accidents that have occurred and they've
said that all of the accidents that
they've looked up were slight accidents
with only one serious accident reported
but that this was was not a um an issue
that um would be exacerbated by the
proposal and therefore they've
reconfirmed that they don't consider
that with only nine units proposed that
there would be any impact on highway
safety so the access is is considered to
be acceptable now in this location with
adequate visibility space which are
conditioned in terms of the actual
turning within the site whilst we're not
agree in the layout at this point again
they have to demonstrate that emergency
vehicles and refuge Vehicles can access
the site and turn and exit in a forward
gear so tracking plans have been
submitted to show that Vehicles can move
into the site turn into the site from
Canterbury Road and they can turn at the
end of the site so we provide tracking
based on a 30 meter vehicle which is the
length of a refuge vehicle and they have
demonstrated that a refuge vehicle can
term within the site so equally a fire
engine could also turn within the site
because that's that's no longer than a
refuge vehicle and could exit in a
forward gear so again there's no
concerns with impact from
um from large Vehicles entering the site
there is space for that to be
accommodated alongside the nine units
so again just to just to look then at
the layout in terms of the layout again
it's not being considered for for
approval at this point because we're not
looking at this aspect of the
application but
um in terms of what can be achieved on
the site
um given the the narrow width for site
and
um the the long length of the site the
only real layout that can be achieved is
is something similar to this
and so it would show an access that
probably extends through the site and
then um this at the moment is showing
um detached units that would extend
along different size units so at the
moment they're proposing a range of two
and three bed units um again we're not
actually approving numbers at this point
or sizes at this point but it is shown
that they could achieve two units at the
front that front onto Canterbury Road
which would be in keeping with the um
the furniture development along
Canterbury Road they could follow the
existing building line it's showing that
the plot sizes would be similar to
existing plot size in the area so again
if you compare it to mil Lodge and Mill
Cottage Mill House the plot sizes are no
different to the plot sizes that you can
see there so it is in keeping with the
surrounding pattern of development
um and uh in terms of like Gardener
sizes they all can achieve uh Dorset
play Space so that that would be um
sufficient in size to serve each unit so
there's in terms of the potential layout
it's considered that this could be
achieved without causing any harm to the
the carrots of the area
um in terms of actual scale and design
again we're not considering scan and
design but again they have provided some
additional information just to show what
could be achieved on the site when
considering it against the impact on on
neighbors and the surrounding area so
this plan they've submitted two section
plans to show how the units could
potentially look and the potential scad
of the units and the potential harm that
could have on any of the neighbors so
there's a section that's provided that
runs along the front of the site onto
Canterbury Road and another section at
the rear so I'm just going to show you
the frontage so this is the the
potential section plan showing the the
frontage onto Cantu Road and how the
units that they've shown on the layout
plan could appear and it shows that
there would potentially be two-story and
we have actually conditioned it to
require that any units would be
two-story because that is the main
character of the area so there's a
condition stating that all of the units
should not exceed two two stories to
each level so there's no chance of there
being anything above that in any future
Reserve matters applications
and it's shown that potentially they
would be able to achieve a traditional
design
um similar to properties that are
currently front and Country Road and
just an indicative pallet material shown
brick and tile hanging which again the
similar materials like that in the road
um you can see that there would be space
in between the proposed dwellings and
the neighbors and then you can see this
Gap here so this isn't part of the
application site so you can see the
actual boundary line here and you see
that this would be an actual spacing
that would exist between the application
site and number 316.
and then further within the site another
section plan has been submitted that
runs along this point here so between
plot a and it runs down through to
um millhaven which is in this location
here
and then this this is the section for
that so again it's just showing the
distances that can be achieved between
the proposed units and neighboring
properties so this was the newly
constructed wedding that you saw in the
photos the White Cloud unit and then
this is Mill Haven on the right hand
side and this would be the um the
vehicular access running along the right
hand side of the site and then you can
see that the existing boundary and
potential
planting along that boundary
so um concern was raised when this was
submitted about what potential impact
there would be on the neighbors because
the Neighbors in particular these three
properties here mail Lodge Mill Cottage
and Mill House do have quite shallow
Gardens so there was concern that any
proposal could actually result in
potential um loss of privacy for these
units so um they have submitted
potential initiative ground floor plans
and first of all plans to show how the
units could potentially be designed in
order to avoid overlooking so
um I'll just show you the first world
honey is more useful but what it shows
is that um
the drainage could be designed so that
the majority of the windows and the main
habitable Windows would actually be on
the rear Innovation
um facing the western boundary of the
site and they wouldn't actually be
direct windows that would face towards
these properties here in terms of
distances
um
the plan show approximately 15 meter 14
meter distances between
um the front elevation of these
properties and the renovation of these
neighbors and so in terms of light and
Outlook that would have been considered
acceptable so again if this application
if a future Reserve matters application
were submitted for this layout we would
have no concerns with Lysol or Outlook
impacts to these neighboring properties
and we are satisfied that the drains
could potentially be designed in a way
that would avoid direct overlooking
um in terms of the properties to the
front again number 316 there's quite a
big gap so it's not considered that
there will be any harm in terms of
lighter Outlet to that neighboring
property and again windows are likely to
be front and back located so there won't
be any um overlooking and for number 310
again it's following the the existing
rear building line and front building
line
um and whilst there may need be a need
to get a slightly wider Gap
um to the boundary again that could be
achieved because they're sufficient and
plot depth there for that to be amended
as part of a future Reserve matters that
became so there won't be any severe harm
to that to there so the impact on
potential impact on Neighbors at this
point in time from this outline
application is is considered to to be
acceptable
so the other issues so I just pop back
to this plant
um so the other issues are to do with
um the I think drainage um is always a
concern that members have so for this
application it's it's not a major
application so they haven't been
required to
um submit uh full drainage details at
this point but I have gone back to them
and requested details for drainage
because I know members are always very
keen to hear what the drainage details
are so the intention of this one would
be for foul drainage for them to connect
onto the existing um foul server and
Southern water have raised no concerns
with that
um and for the surface water drainage
they have the applicant has gone away
and provided some drainage strategy
showing how they would potentially deal
with that and it would be infiltration
within the site either with Shadow
infiltration pits or deep bore soak ways
so again there's a condition proposed
that would require details of the foul
and surface water drainage to be
submitted as as part of a condition but
it's we're quite satisfied at this point
in time that there wouldn't be any harm
to any water source protection area or
any potential flooding from this
development in terms of ecology they
haven't carried out
um any ecology scope in survey but we
have consulted ktc on this and they've
advised that because the site is an
actively
farmed site that the only potential
impact on habitats is probably from the
Hedge boundaries so the head boundaries
probably provide um scope for birds to
Nest within it and so they're concerned
that or not concerned but they're saying
that as long as the Hedgerow along the
boundaries are are retained then the
impacts on ecology is unlikely to be a
concern and so there is a condition that
we've recommended requiring as part of a
future Reserve matters application for
landscaping that the existing Hedgerow
on the eastern boundary is retained and
in addition the new Hedgerow and tree
planting is provided along with
ecological enhancements within the site
and the only other issue could be
bats obviously there's no actual
buildings on the site so there's no
potential for bats to actually sort of
live or breed on the site but they could
potentially fly over and we have lots of
applications where we have to look at
the flight path of bats and how that
could be affected and usually that's
from lighting within the development so
there is a condition proposed that would
require lighting details to come in and
consider the impact on on bats from that
so subject to those conditions the
impact on ecology is is considered to be
acceptable
um it's been mentioned about the Birch
and neighborhood plan
um it it has limited rate but but some
way we have looked through the policies
of the plan and we can't see that this
development would
um fail to like comply with any of those
policies the main policy within the
neighbor within the Berkshire
neighborhood plan is the agricultural
land policy which ties up with the
agricultural land policy within our
local plan for um best and most
versatile land so I think that's the
probably the main consideration within
the birchington neighborhood plan which
is similar to what we're considered
anyway through the the local plan
um it is appreciated it is agricultural
land that is a the loss of that of this
land for agricultural land it is a harm
and that has to be a consideration
um the other harm is the fact it's a
landscape character area and therefore
the loss of this is open space is harm
but this has to be weighed against the
benefits of the scheme the benefits of
the scheme is that we're achieving nine
residential units that are in the urban
area
um and that we have a need for housing
we don't we can't demonstrate the
five-year supply of housing so we have
to be able to approve housing unless
there's harm demonstrated to to stay
otherwise there's an accident to be any
um harm in terms of Consulting responses
that we've received um the access is
consideredly acceptable and we do feel
that nine units can be accommodated on
this site based on the issue plan
submitted and so whilst there is harm
from
um from the loss of the best and
versatile agricultural land and we do
consider it is a very small site it's a
very small loss of that land it's only
0.35 hectares
um and it is considered that the harm is
outweighed by the benefits and therefore
it is recommended that this is approved
we've received the legal agreement that
secures the spa contribution and
therefore subject to that and the
safeguarding conditions it's recommended
for approval thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted with the vice
chair please second second did thank you
I already have had three indications
um to speak so if I could start with
councilor Alban please
yes thank you chair
um
I'm mindful of what's been said by the
wall counselor and also the officer
outlining this um
oh
it all looks rather lovely doesn't it
um where it's situated
with a nice rural Outlet if it's built
nice little Outlook when if it was built
but I suppose that's what the residents
who are currently there like they're
nice rural Outlet Outlook
for me I just think it's in the wrong
place it's just a piecemeal bit of
development that sometimes that the
applicants decided the plant there or
wants to plant there
um
[Music]
the
the open Farmland here we're losing
enough Farmland as it is the
should the the large development go
ahead should it get consent we're going
to lose a lot of Farmland here there is
no need to lose this it doesn't comply
with policy
um
there's no policy for it it's not within
the local plan to be housing
um
we don't require it
because we're getting hundreds of houses
should they be a be approved
and I just can't support it I just I
just think it's the it's the wrong
development in the wrong place thank you
councilor Keane
thank you chair
I don't understand
why this little patch of land was left
out of the allocation in the first place
it may not be a consideration for this
planning committee but there must have
been some reason why the rest of the
field was included and not this
um
yeah as has already been stated it's not
in the local plan and whereby it would
provide nine houses we don't have to
build on every single little bit of
green space that we have left
I'm also quite concerned for the
resident of the Bungalow I don't think
it was stated exactly the distance
between I mean I know this is only an
outline plan but what what space would
there be between that dwelling and The
Bungalow because it looks very close
thank you
[Music]
um Mr Livingstone
would like to come in and answer
nope
someone's coming in
um on the Bungalow point I I don't have
the measurement because as you've just
said quite rightly we're not considering
the layout at this point
um I did mention in my presentation that
I probably would expect as part of
Reserve matters to see a greater spacing
between that plot and The Bungalow but
there is space within that plot to get
maybe a narrow unit and a deeper unit
which would get greater space in so yes
that is something I probably would want
to see because of the fact it is a
bungalow and they've got their
conservative right onto the boundary I
would expect bigger spacing but yes we
can deal with that through the reserve
matters when looking at the layout in
terms of this actual site and the
Strategic allification this site is in a
different land ownership so this one was
not put forward so as part of the site
allocations for the local plan the sites
have to be put forward during our call
for sites
process and this site wasn't put forward
and therefore it hasn't formed part of
the allocation but that's the only
reason there's no reason that we it's
not that we particularly wanted to
protect this piece of and that's why
it's not gone for housing it's just
literally that it's a separate land
ownership and so yes whilst it's
um it's agricultural land it now is in
the urban confines so I appreciate what
members are saying in terms of loss of
um agricultural land but it's also not
now considered Countryside
um so it is slightly unique in that most
the time when we do look at loss of
agricultural land at uga's Countryside
it's usually outside the urban confines
it does give us greater weight to try
and refuse things in this case it does
make it a bit difficult because it does
actually comply with policy h01 and
policy spo1 for the principle of Housing
Development the principle of housing on
this site is acceptable subject to the
loss of the agricultural land
right I have councilor Joanne bright
next
thank you chair
um yeah I wouldn't have an issue with
this development if it were on a
Brownfield site However the fact that
this development would be on Prime
agricultural land not allocating the
local plan is very hard to swallow my
question was the same as as councilor
Keens
um I hadn't realized that it was a
different landowner but even so rather
than giving the green light for these
nine houses do we have grounds to
preserve this strip of Greenfield to
maintain a sense of space and separation
between the existing dwellings and the
Planned new extensive settlement do we
have a responsibility to preserve the
visual immunity of this Greenfield site
for current residents and for future
Generations
okay um thanks um in terms of the
considerations for members I mean
obviously the the development will
result in built form on this strip uh
and obviously in terms of an assessment
of
um qdo2 which is the character
appearance policy members you know as as
officers have to make an assessment on
whether or not this would be in
character with the area or not in terms
of pattern of development but also in
terms of whether or not that open space
is valued I mean what's important to say
is that it's not in the same way it's
not designated for housing specifically
it's also not designated as open space
to be protected it's not public open
space and therefore it hasn't got a
specific designation which automatically
means it needs to be protected so it's a
weighing up process linked to the point
made about agricultural land and the
specific relevance to that policy as to
whether or not members consider that the
development they've proposed in the form
that they've had to propose it because
whilst the layout's not being considered
you can only fit nine houses on this
site with this linear road with one
point of access whether or not that fits
in with the character of the area and
whether or not it would still maintain
the value that members put on it in
terms of the character area or not
councilor bayford
thank you chair I understand that
tonight we're looking at this
application alone but we cannot ignore
the fact that this land has been
designated for building of 1600 homes
allocated in the local plan
this has not
um our speakers tonight have listed many
cogent reasons why this site is
inappropriate I feel that it should
remain either agricultural land or a
green space and that the proposal to
build houses on this would result in
over development thank you
councilor Mata face
thank you chair
um we're considering access take that on
board in the form of a single vehicular
access point from Canterbury Road now
what concerns me is single it doesn't
stipulate car van whatever but nine
houses with one space for access on that
very busy road on Mrs fibbons mentioned
how many vehicles are using there we all
know what the road's like I can just see
massive traffic jams also I agree again
it's not a final application but I'm
concerned that those houses will not
just have one car each they could
possibly have two and possibly even
three I'm just really concerned about
all those houses exiting through one
access point so I'm afraid I'm finding
it very difficult to support this
application and everybody else has said
the points that I would have raised but
that's that's my particular concern okay
um so just just in terms of the access
obviously as as we talked about before
um we obviously look at a number of
dwellings and obviously we get specific
advice from highways about safety of an
access point um and obviously it's a it
is a technical assessment as to both
visibility also width of access so in
terms of evidence that there would be uh
this access would create severe highway
safety concerns to Warrant refusal there
is not the evidence that it would in
terms of the arrangement both in terms
of the highways comment and also when
then applying the test of of the mppf
obviously
um the the officers outlined about the
additional information with regards to
the safety of having access at all and
having nine houses come onto it in terms
of the Canterbury Road but we wouldn't
say that there would be a cogent reason
refusal on that Highway access point
Mr Livingston said severe
gradients of severity in terms of
traffic as you know and I mean
unfortunately we no longer have highways
offices coming to evening meetings which
is a great shame because then we could
ask them for a definition of severe
because an adjective can mean anything
um yeah I I agree fundamentally it's
it's terminology and this is an
interpretation of terminology that's
specifically in the paragraph in the
mppf and highways obviously have to make
a judgment like um anyone making
planning decisions would knowing exactly
what's assessed to appeal
um and also just looking at actually
what has been proposed and because
you're at a point where obviously it's
it's a straight road at this point so
you can get the visibility displays in
they've had to move the access point to
accommodate it so highways obviously
have looked at this point and
specifically asked for amendments to
ensure that it is safe and we're
confident of that
thank you I have councilor Wing next
thank you chair I'd like to thank the
planners actually for uh taking on board
constant concerns over sewerage and
drainage and also habitat so it's good
it's good to hear that that we are going
back to developers to pose questions
about what you're going to do with
surface runoff
uh I I have issues uh with with the road
safety coming from a a a teaching of PE
background near Missy is really
important and those small accidents
should be considered Near misses which
in clearly indicate there is an
increased risk of uh accidents happening
there and sooner or later there's going
to be some serious accidents there I
also think another thing that I hope our
planners will consider in the future is
the the issue of cumulative impact so
this this to me is uh this development
if if it if it goes ahead should should
be seen alongside the potential for the
1600 houses that are planned on the rest
of the land because we need to be
looking we need to start looking at how
a combination of planning applications
that are brought forward because of the
local plan have a cumulative impact on
our communities
uh and it's a slam dunk for me a the
local plan sets up a set of rules by
which we have allocated land for housing
and in allocating how handful land for
housing we have not allocated other land
for housing and we can't just suddenly
decide a piece of land suddenly can be
in the local plan because it's in the
urban confines I mean otherwise why have
we got a local plan and then that gives
us a great opportunity to start
questioning the bits of land that we
have allocated maybe we can knock a bit
off of some of the land we've allocated
if we can suddenly in this meeting add a
bit of land to the local plan so I'm
sorry I won't be I won't be approving
this either thank you
I just want to come back on the points
of the Gods to cumulative impact
um and and about the urban confines so
in terms of cumulative impact
um as in terms of material planning
considerations those are sort of almost
a two-tier process because obviously
allocations in the local plan
um are taken into account however the
important distinction is about whether
or not something's committed development
so whether or not it's got permission or
not so whether or not it has planning
permission at that point obviously it
can be considered within the
relationship with sites next door in
this instance for example and you know
where if if the other site was or if
there was any development that had been
improved next to this site we'd have to
take account of where those dwellings
are in relation to what's being
considered on this application so that
does happen as part of the planning
process and just in terms of
um a proposal coming forward that's not
allocated in the local plan we have lots
of sites in the district that are open
space or undeveloped land we have Garden
land that comes forward for applications
they have to be considered on their own
merits under the policy framework that's
obviously the fundamental test of the
planning act that's got decisions got to
be made in accordance to the development
plan the area this is the development
plan of the area and this is a site
within the urban confines therefore
members are required to consider this
against the housing policy that we have
as to whether or not it Accords with
that or not now it does include the
assessment against other policies in
this instance the loss of agricultural
land is one of those policies and it is
a rare situation where you've got a site
in the urban confines that uh that that
also is actually agricultural land but
that's this is not probably the only
site in the district that has that it's
just that we've obviously got this
proposal in front of us so
it can't be disregarded automatically
just because it's not allocated only
sites of five houses or more are
allocated in the plan the plan makes
provision for housing to come forward
that's not allocated via site-specific
allocation policies so it can't be
disregarded just because it's not
allocated thank you chair
I have counciloratican next
thank you chair um I won't go over uh
the gram because my fellow sort of peers
have all gone over it but um as we said
you know the nine houses it doesn't
weigh to lose that landscape to lose the
alcohol land there so I won't be
supporting the um application
councilor Linda Wright
thank you chair it looks like everybody
else has stolen my script
thank you very much for that um but one
thing there is something
um you haven't mentioned the
archaeologist
archaeological factors have been
involved the developers of the 116 the
1600 houses have actually left a space
to avoid that area because of the the
high value of the archaeological
things there but also I'm looking at a
picture that doesn't even look like the
area this makes this area look like a
really large area whereas Mill Lane is a
very narrow
beautiful quiet little road not not as
wide as any of those and you will never
get more than a couple of cars down that
road
ever
and I I should probably go that I won't
be supporting this application tonight
either
[Applause]
councilor Garner
thank you thanks um yeah I'll take it on
board
I won't repeat what other people have
said I'm pleased to hear what a lot of
other people have said as well
um take it on board what Mr Livingston
said about taking the application on its
own merits
um to my mind this is a speculative
application by the Canterbury diocese
they've taken this opportunity to try
and make fast Buck out of this strip of
land this Prime agricultural land which
we can't afford to lose anymore as has
been mentioned by others that we're
already planning to lose I don't believe
that the um
the positive
the the houses that we're going to get
from this potential development outweigh
the loss of agricultural land
and like the others I won't won't be
sporting this
thank you
okay bikes I'm still Livingstone oh okay
so I just come back on the archeology
Point
um so we did seek a comment from um KCC
on archeology
um he's been very involved with the um
strategic site looking at the
submissions and and work that have been
carried out on that side
um so the conclusion of the kcc's
comment was that they don't raise
objection to it but the the site is very
close to an area that is
um uh that can't be developed through on
the Strategic site
um he they've confirmed that they don't
consider that there would be an impact
on the setting of the ancient Monument
um and that there could be archeology
within this site that need to be
considered so the condition they've
recommended they don't consider that
this there's any anywhere within the
site that would result in exclusion of
development but they do feel that prior
to any reserve matters application being
submitted where we're fixing the layout
that they would need to have carried out
the archaeological work on the site to
see if there's anything on the site that
means that the layout has to be created
in a particular way to avoid those areas
um but overall he doesn't consider that
there's likely to be anything that would
actually prevent the site itself from
being developed but is recommending that
condition
um so that the work's carried out prior
to any submission later on
cancer face can I just ask a question I
accept and it's I mean it was quite
clear this is on by a different
um this is a different owner
um but can I just ask is the whole site
farmed by one tenant farmer but this
strip because it's part of Churchland
has been kept separate and therefore it
wasn't included in SB 16 is that my
understanding is that correct
and from what I understand from the um
applicant the this site and the adjacent
site are all farmed by one farmer who um
leases the land from both the land
owners
okay I don't have any more speakers at
the moment I don't know if Mr Livingston
wants to come back in on any of the last
ones or if you want to go to the vote
in that case we will now put the motion
for the officer's recommendation for
approval to the vote can I have those in
favor
yeah
and those against
thank you
so is hang on we've got the phone number
yep
um so that's uh the motion is lost
um we do need to adjourn for a moment uh
because uh we we need to actually write
a new motion so if there's anyone a
couple of members that feel that they
want to come up to the bank front bench
and uh help write that motion
um please do
I'm sorry I'm sorry we can have I'm
sorry there is no there's no allowance
for speaking from the public gallery
I'm sorry sir there's no allowance for
speaking from the public gallery
I'm sorry sir I have to ask you to sit
down
I'm sorry
please
no I'm sorry all public speaking has
already passed
there is no allowance for speaking from
the public gallery
if you continue I will have to ask you
to leave
just to confirm we'll be back in a
couple of minutes we're just finalizing
the wording
yeah if you can just bear with us for a
moment longer just waiting for councilor
Wing to return to the chamber
all right thank you everyone for your
patience
uh okay we're waiting for some signing
in of the signing in book
[Music]
all right thank you everyone for your
patience um I'm just going to hand back
to Mr Livingstone who is just going to
outline the discussions that have been
had and uh the new proposed motion
thank you chair
um so the discussion was around
um potential reasons for refusal for the
application trying to
um acknowledge the points that members
have raised and specifically relating
that to the policy framework as outlined
in the presentation this is a slightly
unique site and so much as that it is
within the urban confines but members
um in in the majority raised concerns
specifically about
the loss of open space and the impact on
the character of the area and obviously
officers have outlined about the
characteristics of the the landscape
character area specifically designated
as such and also the loss of
agricultural land which has been
obviously clearly mentioned by a number
of members uh when you've been looking
at the test on the under the policy so
two reasons for refusal for a new motion
would be that the proposal by virtue of
its location and form would result in
the loss of open space and harm to the
characteristics of the central landscape
undulating chalk farm land landscape
character area where the need for an
impact from the development has not been
demonstrated to outweigh the need to
protect than its landscape character and
local distinctiveness with the visual
harm resulting from the additional built
form not sufficiently outweighed by
economic social or environmental
benefits contrary to policies SP 26 and
qdo2 of the found local plan and
paragraphs 130 and 174 of the mppf
and then the second reason for refusal
would be the proposed development would
result in the irreversible loss of
bessemer's versatile agricultural land
the poses failed to demonstrate the
benefits The Proposal would outweigh the
harm arising for the loss of
agricultural land and that no other
suitable sites of poor agricultural
quality can accommodate the development
or lead to a likely accumulated of
significant losses to high quality
agricultural land The Proposal would
therefore be contrary to policy e16 of
the local plan and paragraph 100 and
power of 174 of the mppf
thank you can have a proposal
Melbourne and secondary councilor
sorry Council accept secondary councilor
Garner thank you
and can I have those in favor
and those against
and any abstentions
thank you that is carrot
um just to confirm for those of the
members of public in the gallery
what that means is the application has
been refused
thank you
[Applause]
and we'll move on to a gender item 4D
122 North down Road speaking in favor of
the application is Mr Graham Kinnear you
have three minutes if you can just pause
while
repeat people are leaving thank you
um thank you madam chair
um I understand that this application
has been called in as a result of policy
cv1 within the cliftonville development
plan which suggests that consent for one
bedroom Flats should not be permitted
um this policy includes a geographic
area which Falls outside the location of
122 Northtown Road and therefore we
don't feel there's any policy currently
in place which would prevent consent
being awarded in respect of one bedroom
Flats
indeed if you look at the local plan
policy SP 13 it talks about the ability
for people to access good quality
housing and to be able to live
independently and a key consideration of
this must be affordability
I had a search on one of the internet
sites for available rented accommodation
in cliftonville up to 900 pounds a month
and there were three available based on
an average salary for planets according
to the ons the rent for a one bedroom
flat would be 38 of an individual's
take-home pay and the policies that were
previously in place in respect of one
bedroom Flats were at a time where they
were plentiful in Supply and around half
their current cost
policy ho21 states that proposals to
bring property to residential use will
be approved whether they are compatible
with nearby uses the split level masonet
proposed to the rear of 122 Northtown
Road utilizes part of the commercial
space and therefore on this description
should be approved bearing in mind the
neighboring uses on either side are both
residential furthermore by adapting the
size of the retained commercial unit
we've been able to attract a tenant
retain the shop unit and the Heritage
shop front and assist in a local
business which is clearly a further
stated aim of the local Authority
looking at the comments with regards to
the application there was a concern with
regards to refuse collection noting a
difficulty of collecting from the rear
in Clifton Place a collection is already
undertaken from Clifton Place to the
existing basement apartment at 122
Northern Road and this has been the case
since 2003 and we do not see how
collecting from one additional apartment
from the same location as an existing
collection should promote any
difficulties though we do also note from
the officer's report that it is
considered acceptable to us the
occupiers to walk their referees to the
front of the premises if that's deemed
necessary
our scheme as far as we can see complies
with all stated local plan and Regional
objectives and we therefore hope it can
be approved thank you for your time
thank you I have no other speakers so
I'll hand over to the planning
applications manager to outline the
report thank you chair
so the application is for the change of
use of 122 involving the basement ground
floor and first floor to create three
new residential units so two one bed and
one bed set with the retention of the
office use on ground floor which fronts
North down Road and the Two Flats above
it on the front part of the site's first
floor and second floor so their existing
residential units that are being
retained there is also could I just come
in on that I I I'm I'm unfortunately not
I'll go through the just to confirm
sorry chair if it's okay I'll be going
through the existing plan so you'll be
able to so members will be able to see
exactly what the layout is that has been
submitted just to confirm that point
great
at the moment
there can be no coming back sorry for
the discussion after you've spoken I I'm
happy to read that out again what I said
was two one bed and one bed proposed so
it's three units in total but
okay I will go through the plans of
members and I can confirm what's
obviously shown on the plans in terms of
what's what's been put forward so in
terms of the site this is the red line
around the application site
um you've got a frontage to North down
Road
um and uh the rear of the axis as
mentioned at Clifton Place
in terms of the site itself so you've
got um
122 is the the second property in from
Clifton Road so you've got 120 on the
corner and then you've got the property
itself
um next door
so this is the front of the property
and then if we go around the corner so
this is down the side road here so just
looking towards the area to the rear of
um this two-story flat roof extension
where you can see a roof pitching away
and then you've got this um showing the
the pitch of the roof uh away there so
just a reference point because we'll be
looking at the separate
um the separate elevation plans so you
can see where the scaffolding is there
again
um and then just another view back
towards the rear of the property
so then this is a view from Google
Street View which just shows the the
building that's on the corner and then
you've got Clifton Place down down the
side and then going round and then
looking from Clifton Place you can see
the pitch of the roof that we're seeing
from the side road where the proposed
alterations to the roof are going to
occur and then there's the the
Scaffolding in place there
then we've got a bit of a view back
towards the rear of the property and and
this is again from Google Street View so
you can see the scaffolding is now not
there but you can see some of the
landscaping that's covered in the report
on the uh on the site
so this is the front elevation of the uh
of the existing so what's being proposed
here is you have
the reinstatement of the iron railings
at first floor level that you can see
added in you then have excavation to
create a light well with railings along
the front with a new window to be
inserted at a basement level on the on
the North elevation
um so
then going to the existing section so at
the moment you have at the rear you have
the the what is the ground floor and
then you have basement at the moment
underneath you also have a a basement
area that actually goes underneath the
road which is not accessible and has not
been put for as part of this proposal
um so then looking then at the elevation
of what's existing so you can see the
basement at the back at the moment which
has been mentioned in terms of
accommodation and then
what's proposed is then if you look on
the left hand side you can see that the
sort of elevation showing the light well
showing the access down to the basement
flat and you can also see what's being
proposed at the rear so you've got new
staircase down uh at the rear you've
also got an extension to change the roof
so this the eaves height of the existing
Outrigger is to increase in height
that's to be clad um in in white Timber
cladding you've then got some roof
lights within a new slate roof slope so
then that is the roof that we I was just
referring to so the eaves will increase
with then the roof pitching away
so in terms of the rear elevation this
is the existing elevation again you can
see that pitch at the moment just to go
before I show you that elevation just to
show you again the neighboring property
you can see that the the rear extension
is actually quite a bit higher than the
existing building so it's worth
reference to that when looking at the
proposal so then this is as I say the
existing
what's being proposed then is that the
roof will be changed it will pitch away
there is an increase in height from
Ridge height of of 1.6 which is what the
officers provided in terms of the
measurement but obviously the actual
height of that roof is moving away from
that neighboring boundary because this
is the rear with a new window that's
facing out from it
so this is just then the internal
elevation so you've got the wall of of
Clifton place and then the internal
elevation
and then you've got the section that
shows through the new accommodations to
be put at first floor
um so at the moment as mentioned what
you've got is
um a unit of accommodation which is uh
down in the basement you can see they've
got the bathroom at the rear so what
what just to give members an idea we're
looking North down roads on the
left-hand side of the plan uh and then
at the rear of the plan is it's Clifton
Place which is on the right hand side of
this plan just so you can get an idea of
what we're talking about so what's
proposed here is a change in the the the
types of of accommodation that's being
proposed so you've got unit 122 A which
will now be accessed from the front so
you've got this unit here which will be
a a one bedroom unit you've got change
to the rear accommodation so you've got
a one bedroom Studio which is to be at
the basement level here so you've got
the using the existing Windows face out
but you've got a new staircase that
accesses from the rear
then you've got the existing Planet
ground floor level so on the left hand
side of the image you can see there is
uh the office that's there at the moment
and you can see how there's an existing
access that goes from North down road to
access both the upper floors and and the
basement
what's changing here then
is that you've got this new access at
the rear to get into the new unit which
is uh sort of within the ground floor at
the back but also then up to the first
floor you've also got bin storage in the
rear Courtyard that's being shown at the
right hand side of the image so you can
see in the central part of this image
you've got the shower room and the
bedroom and then you're going up to a
kitchen and Lounge which is within that
pitch roof slope from that alteration to
the roof that's been proposed with roof
lights and then the rear window that's
that's facing out
and then this is the Upper Floor Plan to
show the um the the roof lights
um
so in terms of the main considerations
to the primary considerations are for
the creation of the units are you know
are the living conditions that are being
created sufficient and is there an
impact on neighboring properties we've
also got the impact on the conservation
area so there are a number of conditions
which are being proposed which would
relate to materials and joinery details
of the new window that you can see on
this elevation here as well as the
details of the railings at the front the
conservation officer has commented in
the application and does consider The
Proposal with those conditions would be
acceptable in respecting the character
of the conservation area and not
resulting in harm to it there are
examples along this row of Northtown
Road of of this sort of excavation or
light Wells with railings similar to
this in terms of
the rear as mentioned you will see from
Clifton Road and Clifton Place the
extension that's being proposed in the
alterations to the roof again given the
collection of buildings that are around
there and there are different materials
that are used in terms of render brick
that we don't consider that there'll be
a harmful impact on the conservation
area by virtue of the introduction of
the extension which will be be cloud in
the in the timber cladding again we'll
be getting a a sample of that as part of
the planning conditions and then in
terms of what's being created in terms
of living conditions of the rearranged
units are both basement and also the the
first floor part so one of the issues
that we've been looking at is in terms
of the the layout of those units
um the report talks about the assessment
under qdo4 in terms of the technical
standards now it's worth noting
obviously as mentioned that there are
exist there is existing accommodation
within this prop property but we are you
know required to consider the
arrangement that's being created and
whether or not the arrangement would
affect either existing units in the
basement or indeed the new units that
are being proposed so the report does
look into
um you know how how that sits um in
terms of the assessment that we always
do with qdo4 is we look at the minimum
space standards now in this instance
because the nature of these units being
effectively one bed units the
distinction comes between what is a one
bed one person unit and a one bed
two-person unit now the criteria defines
those in terms of the spaces that are
provided the minimum size of a bedroom
could be defined as a two-person unit
however planning does not have the
ability to control who actually occupies
the dwelling so it's not for us to say
You must only rent this to one person
rather than two per people so we have to
kind of take the two potentials here in
the round and consider whether or not
what's being proposed is quality
accommodation now it's considered by
officers that because of the shape of
these rooms and because of the fact they
do have Outlook some of it is restricted
by virtue of being at basement level but
because of the shapes of these rooms
that are being created
um you know especially when you're
looking at what is the mazonet at the
rear
um which is obviously the new the the
definitive new unit of accommodation
that because of the shape of the space
that's created we do think that this
would be sufficient to create decent
living accommodation which is usable we
have had appeals before where we've
refused applications which have been
contrary to qdo4 and the assessment that
the inspector has done specifically a
case in Westgate has been on the basis
of what's the space like you know can
you put Furniture in this space and in
reality with these this layout you can
do that in terms of the point about bin
storage
um this is obviously at the moment there
is access for the properties upstairs
you know in terms of putting bin storage
out at the back cliftonville Clifton
Place as mentioned does have a bin
collection that occurs however obviously
it is less than ideal given the width of
that given getting a vehicle down there
is difficult and we've already talked
about 13 meter Vehicles this evening so
you can understand how it's difficult to
maneuver down that sort of space we do
consider to be to have to put the bins
at the front it's not overly onerous for
occupiers they are like likely to have
something more akin to sort of see gold
proof bags rather than wheelie bins
although either way you've got a space
in the rear your yard to have them and
then the ability to walk around without
it being again a carry distance that is
prohibitive so on balance we consider
that the proposal could be accepted for
the accommodation as shown there is a
recommendation to defer and delegate and
that is because we would still be
seeking the legal agreement to secure
the contributions towards the special
protection area because there's new
residential units being created and
therefore it is recommended for a to be
deferred and delegated to officers for
approval subject to the safeguarding
conditions and the receipt of a
satisfactory legal agreement thank you
chair
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation for approve for deferral
is adopted with the vice chair please
second seconded
thank you
I do have a couple of indications of
speaking but who else just
um
yeah
okay counselor Keane first
thank you chair I called this in
originally because I mistakenly did
think it was in the cliftonville
development plan area which does
um rule against more one-bedroom Flats
so although it is just outside that area
and I accept that the fact is it is one
of the most densely populated areas of
thanet and I don't think what we need is
more development along these lines in
this area it's just not what's needed
but I'm also very concerned about the
development proposals in terms of the
quality of accommodation that they will
afford people and the
space that's available I think it's over
development that there's going to be you
know even higher buildings at the back
there and as I say I think that's over
development so I look forward to hearing
how other people view these plans but
I'm still not convinced thank you
councilor ratican
thank you chair
um the the building's been quite a nice
or sort of building building but the
actual plans there seem to bring in the
character of the building back
um I take sort of note
um one of my colleagues saying about one
bedroom
um properties but I think at the moment
there's quite a bit demand for a lot of
sort of sort of older generation where
landlords are set up the houses and and
I sit on Facebook every single day
people are asking for one one bedrooms
so I think
um it would bring a good new supply to
the era so I would support the
application
councilor Mata face
thank you chair I'm just my concern is
one two two a this is the basement unit
because the report covers the mppf
requires development to provide a higher
standard of amenity for existing and
future use with all windows serving
primary habitable rooms required to have
an acceptable level of Outlook natural
light and ventilation for the rooms
I'm a bit concerned about this basement
with the light well I mean I appreciate
there are properties in cliftonville
with basements but they've been there a
lot of them for a hundred years and I'm
just wondering whether we should be
supporting somebody living basically at
that lower level particularly
with the angle of the light and I would
like to ask Mr Livingston um the
basement where would the light actually
be coming from I mean which direction
north south because if it's coming from
the north
that basement flat will have virtually
no natural light at all particularly in
the winter
thanks yeah I can come back on that um
so the um in terms of that that point
about Outlook and light specifically
you're absolutely correct that is a
definite consideration for this
application and specifically with
regards to there is a you know the the
the plans indicate there is an existing
basement unit however obviously there is
still the creation of units you know you
know the basement the issue here is the
the lounge Diner area
um one of the things that we had to look
at was the size of sorry if I kind of
right plan up
uh where are we there we go the size of
the wind at the basement is quite
important here in terms of the front
because that is effectively Northeast
facing so in terms of the light you get
from that it would be constrained by
virtue of its location but that's why
you need to maximize the size of the
opening to allow as much light as
possible within that light well so in
terms of that specifically we do
consider that needs to be taken in the
round in terms of the the amount of
light that will get when looking then at
the fact that there is uh sorry I'm just
trying to find the rear renovation now
of that one so if I go back to the
uh yeah that one will do it so um in
terms of
the window that's sort of behind the
railings here
um so you have a
there we go so you have a window that's
if you can see my mouse where it's
probably going down you have a window in
that elevation which we just looked at
so that is serving the bedroom and
obviously that sorry I'm forgetting
where the plans are apologies uh it's uh
there we go right okay
um so the bedroom at the back there
um obviously does have a longer outlook
on Italy it is in a constrained area but
it's a longer Outlook it's also facing
in a direction that will get quite a bit
of light because of the nature of where
it faces
um specifically the fact that it's
pretty much South
um so you will get like a lot of of the
of the time now it is constrained around
the back you know we saw from those
images that there are two story
buildings around there but we again
that's why it's important to take it in
the round with regards to the amount of
space that's provided and how open that
space is and that's why it's been
designed with those two primary main
spaces uh being looked at so again it is
a balance and is a judgment but we think
that it is acceptable but it is a it's a
point to raise yes
and councilor bayford
thank you chair
well the conservation officer doesn't
believe there to be a negative impact on
the area
I think we have a huge need for one
bedroom accommodation
particularly for the diverse range of
business people and in fact for anyone
who doesn't wish or cannot afford to pay
for bedrooms that will not be used so I
will be supporting this application
thank you I don't appear to have any
other speakers so we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for deferral to the vote can I have
those in favor
and those against
us
yeah so the motion is carried thank you
so moving on to item 4E British Heart
Foundation 113 to 117 High Street
Margate speaking in favor of the
application Mr Steve Barr you have three
minutes
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity of allowing me to speak uh
briefly about the change of views
application for the British Heart
Foundation Building at 113-117 High
Street you may be aware that the
separate prior approval application is
currently being considered by officers
to extend the building that application
is not before members tonight and we
wish to clarify the scheme that is being
considered can be built out by itself
um as set out in the application
material
now the proposals seek to create three
times two bedroom and one times one
bedroom residential units at first floor
so four units in total
all units are to National Space
standards and our dual aspects so
windows on both sides and the scheme
will also retain an active retail
Frontage at ground level which addresses
the pedestrianized pavement Zone and
responds to The Wider character of The
High Street
three smaller retail units will be
formed at the ground floor level rather
than a single large unit which will be
vacated when the current lease expires
the smaller units encourage more
diversity and offer greater commercial
viability where larger units are no
longer required within Town centers the
scale of the units is also more in
keeping with the shops at this end of
the High Street
as part of the development the building
elevations will be improved increasing
their thermal performance
and they will replace the heavy concrete
cladding described by officers as
austere
with a mix of new glazing which has been
introduced to to allow adequate daylight
following analysis of the plans and to
have light gray infield panels in
between
the overall proposals are in accordance
with the nppf which recognizes that
residential use is play an important
role in ensuring the Vitality of town
centers
and therefore encourages residential
development on appropriate sites the
scheme is car free and is provided with
secure cycle storage facilities
and aligns with your sustainable
transport policies tp03 and tp06 the
development also has communal amenity
space at roof level and designated
refuse and recycling areas surfacing
will be from the rear as currently
exists for the British heart foundation
and we don't anticipate if consented
that construction would also take place
from the rear side of the building we
clearly hope that the committee will
support the proposals before you
um which will I think sustainably
deliver both new homes and contemporary
retail space and ensure that an existing
structure with high embodied energy
within its concrete frame uh will be
successfully repurposed thank you
thank you speaking under Council rule
20.1 councilor Helen Whitehead you have
three minutes
thank you chair
one of the key issues that requires
consideration here is outlined clearly
on page 104 of today's agenda
the Constitution does not currently
allow for prior notification
applications to be called in by members
for consideration at planning committee
as they fall under the permitted
development process and are not classed
as planning applications
the problem here is that currently there
is no right to request scrutiny of what
are often very significant developments
which means that the only way to attempt
to look at significant infrastructure
changes is to address it via the
principal application
the committee and scrutiny system is
vital to planning and being unable to
call in on prior notifications makes the
system that is already incomprehensible
to the vast majority of residents even
more incomprehensible
because if your issue is with further
development of two stories effectively
altering the skyline and light and
potentially access to current residents
and Shop owners it is a very strange
concept to be unable to call that
application in because it is somehow not
considered to be a significant
alteration
these applications will become more
common and the confusion linked to them
more widespread because of this and
because of Resident concerns I felt it
was very important to call in the
current application and so it is the
only way to have a general discussion
relating to how the usage of Prior
notification will affect the planning
landscape and affect residents and their
ability to be heard within the system
as it stands currently we have to my
mind a fairly standard conversion
application here although I would
question whether it is eo4 compliant as
I would argue that shops such as this
perform very specific function in terms
of the maintenance of the shopping
center larger shops allow for specific
usages such as purchase of furniture and
in an area of deprivation this is very
significant and necessary function of a
shopping area
I do think that it is arguable that the
production of three smaller shops when
we already have a significant number of
smaller shops does undermine the
function of the center
to close I would like to reference page
104. it is therefore recommended that
members approve the application subject
to assigned unilateral undertaking being
received and the addition of
safeguarding conditions
currently we have residents concerned
about loss of immunity stresses related
to parking and congestion on what is
already an exceptionally busy and
challenging Road loss of light loss of
character and potential loss of trade
due to a significant change in trading
environment relating to two floors and
six units of accommodation that they are
not permitted to call into planning we
currently have no designs for these or
any recognition of the concerns of
current residents or to my knowledge
plans to mitigate the prior notification
to accommodate these concerns and as a
counselor I am unable to raise those
concerns other than in relation to this
application
I would like members to consider the
issue of how our constitution deals with
prior notification applications and the
potential of safeguarding conditions as
they relate to what is currently a very
challenging area of planning law thank
you
thank you the principal planning officer
will now outline the report
this is the application site here so
you've got Margate High Street on the
left a Herbert place on the right
um this is the multi-story car park in
this location here
and this aerial view of the site so you
can see it's quite a large unit within
the High Street
and then a view again here so this is
the unit in this location here so it's
quite a wide unit when looking at the
width of other Pro other commercial
units within the High Street you can see
that it is
um
quite a different design to the other
units with quite a harsh concrete
Frontage and windows set back in between
which you'll see better with the photos
in a moment again this is the site here
so you can see the multi-story car park
here Herbert place and this again is the
application site so it's a currently a
two-story flat roof building
and this is it from The High Street so
this is the the site here British Heart
Foundation unit so it's commercial at
ground floor level the application is
proposing to split the commercial
element to provide three commercial
units
um the site
um lies within the secondary Frontage of
the local plan which does allow for a
variety of use at the ground floor level
but they're looking to retain the
commercial use
um so through the proposal they're
looking to add some additional doors to
create three entrances to the three shop
units So currently there's two entrances
and there would then be three as part of
the proposal and then you can see at
first floor level the current design of
the building with these uh concrete
projections and the windows in between
so again you can see here these are the
current windows in between and the
proposal is to to remove these in large
the windows and then replace the
concrete with a different form of clad
in
so again you can see the view of it from
the other side of the High Street and
then again it's context around other
commercial units
and then again here it is on the left
hand side so again you can see the the
size of the other units um and width of
those buildings in relation to it and
then this is from the rear so from
Herbert place so again this is the
application site here
and then again in the distance here and
then another further view just you can
see in the context of the Montessori car
parts this building here and then going
back to it again this is it so this part
the back projects further and this bit
on the left hand side is currently set
in and so the proposal was looking to do
a slight extension so the building line
of this setback section would come
slightly closer to the road
and again just a view of the existing
building so this is the current rear
access into the building and that would
retain and the xso whilst it would
change in design slightly the access
would still be for this location here up
to the first floor level and also would
provide rear access to the Refuge area
for the commercial and residential areas
and again this is just showing the rear
here and again you can see the um
existing bin window so there is
some that looks like there's a two
parking spaces currently associated with
the building and the site does lie
within
um tp06 of the planet local plan which
doesn't actually require parking because
it's expected to be a very sustainable
location so there's not actually a
requirement for parking to be provided
with new developments within this area
so it's only within the very tight areas
of the very main part of the Town Center
that that area covers and this Falls
within it the site lies just outside of
the conservation area as well so and
whilst we do have a view from the
conservation officer it's just about the
impact on the setting of The adjacent
Conservation Area is not actually within
itself so
um this is just the proposed block plan
so it's basically showing the ground
floor level but also in relation to the
surrounding area so it's showing at
ground floor level you'll see the the
subdivision to create three commercial
units with the three um shop front um
door entrances being created you can see
at the rear
is the access that we're coming and
provide position access up to the first
floor level residential refuge and
recycling is in this location here
commercial Recycling and refugees in
this location here and some cycle
storage for the commercial unit at the
back as well so in terms of the
extension you can see this is the area
on the right hand side which was where
the two cars were parked so there is a
small expansion of the unit to remove
that space you would result in a lot of
that that parking for those two units
but you're backing onto a multi-story
car parts there is parking nearby
um there this is the existing basement
floor area
and this is the existing ground floor so
this is again the existing commercial
retail unit you can see how it's laid
out so you can see the rear access back
and then this again a sort of more
detailed view of that ground floor unit
so you'll see in the subdivision so the
actual subdivision of units itself
doesn't actually acquire permission it's
the shop front alterations that require
the consent
um so it's it's in terms of the the
point that was raised in terms of the
the loss of the large unit that itself
because there's already two um entrances
into it in theory they could actually
subdivide it into two without any
planning permission
um but this is the subdividing this into
three increasing an extra access so this
is why this itself is requiring consent
then at first floor level
um it's currently uh storage straight
retail use associated with the ground
floor level and so again just a large
open space and you can see the the rear
elevation companies at the back here so
they're looking to demolish parts of
this and create a new um two-story
extension in this location here and open
up the central area so this is the
proposed first floor plan so it's to
create three two bed units at the front
and a one bed unit at the back so this
area here that you can see this is all
open so this is like a walkway area with
some planting in front of the units they
these are the front doors to those flat
units
um cycle storage is in this location
here on the left top left and then for
the single one bed unit the um access is
at this point here
so all of the units meet the National
Space standards in terms of the the
actual main habitable rooms they have
the main windows on the front onto the
High Street so that the large double
bedroom and the
um Lounge area would have that main
Frontage and then the single bedroom
would have a window at the rear that
were facing to the space so there is
there's some um limited harm on that
second bedroom of each of the flats
because the Outlook isn't um the best
um and there would be some issues with
privilege because of people walking
along this walkway so they are actually
proposing to obscure glaze some of these
windows so that there's no privacy in
terms of window to window and to avoid
people walking along looking into those
rooms and so that is the only real harm
from from it being provided but overall
the flats are a good proportions
um and they have uh secretary windows at
the rear to serve the main habitable
space
and then at first whatever there's a
communal meansy space so there would be
um it's not we wouldn't actually class
it's Dorset play Space because of it
being on on the roof and we don't have
to argue that they are Dorset Place
based areas but they are providing
external media space to serve the units
um so you'll I'll just show you the
elevation so this is the existing front
elevation and then this is the proposed
so the top one's just a more blown up
version of the ground floor of the lower
one here which is the street elevation
so you can see what they're doing is
removing the clad in widening the
windows the windows would be adding
minion framed and then at ground floor
level they're creating the three um
entrance doors again with aluminum
frames
um this area this bit on top is the um
bad Australian that serves a community
space so that's much further back on the
building you wouldn't actually see that
from street level
um in terms of the actual scale of the
building it's not increasing so the
height of the building is not increasing
through this application
and we consider probably the
improvements really are an enhancement
to the front elevation in terms of how
it sits within the street scene
um this is the existing rear elevation
again you saw that from the photos that
this bit on the left was the setback
part of The Proposal on this on the
right was the the doors closer to the
road and this is now The Proposal with
um some new windows and windows in this
location and the new entrance doors
going up to the flats above
and then this is just a side view of the
existing
um use so you can see the multi-story
car park on the left here and this is
the existing building and then sit
proposed so scale wise there's not
really any change with the change in the
um rear elevation
and then this is it from the other side
so we're getting the car park on the
right and it's going from that to that
so there's not much change in terms of
that scale and then just this is just
going to show you now a section running
through the middle of the site so this
is taken from um the side looking
through just so you can see the
relationship between these windows and
so this is the existing building and
then this is the proposed so you see
this is the first four flats this is the
High Street on the right hand side and
then there will be um this gap between
the windows this being the walkway for
the units and this up here is the
community space external community space
and to serve the unit so it's it's
beneficial
um they normally would require any way
doorstep play Space because they're two
bed units but usually with Town Center
locations the sites that you do quite
restricted and we would usually
um say well it's not easy to achieve
external space so it is quite beneficial
to have this even if it is at roof level
and then these are some sections just
showing the internal elevations so this
is the internal elevation of the rear
elevation of the front section and
that's the renovation of the rear
section so the the single one bed unit
um
so overall we consider it so it's
pleased to land it achieves the
provision of four additional residential
units in a very sustainable location and
there's not a requirement for for
parking given the policy requirements it
it remain retains commercial ground
floor level and we would end up with
three
um commercial units and overall the the
changes to the building are considered
to be an enhancement
um
that separately there is the prime the
private approval application that is in
and that's not before members at this at
this moment in time that prior approval
application is for additional flaws to
be added to the building which
um I believe is is the concerns that are
being raised by residents and Ian's
going to talk about the prior
notification application
um but for the purposes of this
application it is recommended to be
deferred and dedicated for approval
subject to the um unilateral undertaking
coming in to secure the SBA contribution
and safeguarding conditions thank you
thank you Emma um so just to give some
context to members with regards to the
prior approval process so
um this specifically relates to a series
of Provisions that were introduced in
2020 by the government to change the
general limited development order to
include um class 20
um those members that were around at the
time may rare recall a member's briefing
where we talked about this and the
change to the use classes order so
um the the processes for prior approvals
that you can apply to increase the
height of buildings if you're creating
dwelling house dwelling houses
um they are when I say dwelling houses I
mean Flats
um and in that instance there are
specific criteria but if it's a single
story building you can only go up by one
story if it's if it's two-story you can
go up by two or more
um but it's adding two floors as a
maximum on top of buildings now
the way these are looked at
um because previously the gpdo sorry the
general purpose developmental has
multiple types of Prior approval
application but that usually is linked
very specifically to a light touch
process which means that if we don't
determine those applications within a
certain time scale they are
automatically granted so this has come
up previously when we've talked about
telecommunications masts for example if
that's not determined within 56 days
that's automatically granted you have
various other developments of office to
resi and various other little bits and
pieces where this is the case now when
these Provisions were brought in in 2020
that 56 day deadline was not included in
the government's Provisions so what that
means is that there is
um there is a still a requirement for us
to assess certain matters but there is
not that immediate time need to
determine it before it's automatically
granted
under the current Constitution the way
that these prior approvals are looked at
is that they're not included on the
weekly list that's sent round to all of
you because they're not planning
applications and that stems originally
from that 56-day issue because obviously
it could be called in we only have a
committee once once a month things could
go out of time and automatically get
granted so that was the the general idea
behind it
and prior approvals have been in in
around for quite some time but this is
slightly different so we have a priority
of application in it does not form or
cannot influence the decision that
you're making on this planning
application but I think as it's been
raised I think is relevant that you're
aware of of this
um now that type of Prior approval does
allow for consideration of Highways and
transportation impacts impact on
Residential Properties or buildings
adjacent in terms of overlooking light
loss of privacy flooding risks external
appearance of the principal Innovation
and side elevations
it includes whether or not there's
adequate natural light in in the
dwellings that are being created and
various other factors that can be looked
at that is subject to a public
consultation process so the plans are
online and we have received comments on
that prior approval however this is an
example which has come forward where it
is has been considered and been put
forward that it's it's
um considered relevant to gain member
scrutiny on the proposal and look at
those specific criteria so it's not
quite the same as applying all the local
plan policies we've got very specific
criteria that can be looked at so what I
am going to do is review with the
Democratic services manager and also the
head of Legal Services the provisions
around the inclusions of Prior approval
applications where there is no automatic
approval that occurs after 56 days on
the weekly list for members to be able
to potentially call these types of
applications to planning committee he's
worth noting this is the probably I
think the second one in three years so
this does not come about very often
which is why there isn't a process in
place and separately as well we'll
discuss the other prior approval
application because it has obviously
been expressed as an interest that it's
called in front of members but that is a
separate consideration to the
application for you tonight and so we
can revert and provide more information
about that in due course
um but yeah just wanted to outline about
the context for members thank you
thank you I move that the officer's
recommendation for deferral is adopted
could the vice chair please second
seconded
and do I have any speakers councilor
Byford
foreign
thank you Mr Livingstone for clarifying
those points I believe these changes
would enhance this area at the top of
the High Street retail space would
remain although it would be it will be
changed and will there will also be four
new
um housing units created so I'd like to
support this application
councilor wing
I'd like to agree with that but I just I
just needed some clarity it was one ugly
building and it's a definite Improvement
going forward I I think that the
division of uh larger resident larger
retail units into smaller ones is a
positive move because
in in Ramsgate for example we've got a
number of large retail units that are
just sat there empty so I see that as a
benefit as well although I do I do get
that if we lose all our big ones then
then there is a disadvantage
Mr Livingstone could I just uh could I
just confirm that uh because I like this
and I'm of a mind to improve it approve
to vote with the motion but
did you say that the prior approval will
come back will come back to us so then
we can consider that bit because that
does worry me what might happen on top
and if it's of the same quality then
probably we're not going to have an
issue but it would be like would be nice
to see that
um so I will just be discussing with the
as I said the Democratic service
emergent had a legal with regards to I
believe that I'm I believe there is
provision within the Constitution to
allow it on the basis of if it's agreed
by myself and the chair that there is
significant public interest in that type
of application coming forward
um that it could
um but I'm gonna we're gonna review that
after this meeting
um I think it's worth noting as well
that application is still being
considered they're still back and forth
on that proposals which is allowed so
you know it's still undergoing that
process so we're not at a point where
it's it's going to be determined
tomorrow I think that's just an
important point and I I will be
clarifying after this meeting what the
next steps are for that
I could ask another question
and he's gone right out of my head now
it's gone
it's gone he said there's still been a
long day in that in that case uh if you
don't mind I'll move to Council of Ghana
I might remember thank you yeah yeah I I
agree with councilors bayford and Wing
about the about the the design for this
um I mean one of the key
things with this I think which is
important that does help me like it is
the communal space
on the roof for the four four Apartments
I mean with the if that wouldn't that
can't be guaranteed obviously because um
with the prior approval if that comes
through that's gone so then you've got a
roof space for
three times this amount of accommodation
quite a lot higher up with less play
playroom for children
well I can think of some children I
wouldn't mind playing up there but but
so that's one of the one of the um one
of the downsides of this but I guess as
we can only look at this application as
it is as it is I'd like it and I'll but
I would like to think that both yourself
and the planning applications manager
would after listing trust be minded to
let us have a view of the um prior
application
um when it when it's available for us to
see thank you
um okay I'm I will bring councilor Wing
back in I think it I think her thought
has come back to her I had a senior
moment it was just a bit of
clarification so is prior approval
generally used for an extra bit on a
building which isn't being developed
because this is I think the unusual
thing here may be that we've got one
building which is going to be
extensively developed and then we've got
a prior approval on top of it uh so am I
assuming that normally we have a
building that isn't as extensively
developed and there's a prior approval
to extend a bit on an existing building
um I think I mean the the fact that
there are two up one planning
application one prior approval on on the
site is you know again we haven't had as
I say many of these upward extension
prior approvals but there's nothing you
know there is nothing untoward about
doing it the way that's been done you
know this is this is the the ability to
do it is is this way but there is
obviously a you know again creating
committed development by proving this
one naturally does mean it has to be
sort of considered when you're looking
at the prior approval but they do stand
independently in terms of the
considerations to that extent
just one quick question
um the one that the flat at the back
is that access from her place or is that
access I've seemed to kind of it's a bit
difficult looking at where's the access
to the one at the back because I know it
talks about this walkway on the first
floor but how would the people in the
fourth one
the doors in this location here for this
unit so all of them all of the flats are
accessed from the walkway so the doors
for these units are here and this door
is here so they'd all come up the steps
and I'm on the walkway
[Music]
uh uh
we just
sorry hang on hang on there you go so
here's all the stairs at the back so um
so there's a I'm not sure which stairs
of which actually but you've got the
door there with the stairs and you've
got door there upstairs so one of those
goes up yeah
[Music]
all right it doesn't look like we've got
any more questions um just to respond to
councilor Garner from just now yes I
will be liaising with
um Mr Livingstone and uh any uh debate
about that follows on from discussions
with Democratic services and legal and
if it is appropriate and we can bring
the prior approval to this committee
then we will but also we need to resolve
the issue for
um it doesn't happen often but for any
future applications that may happen so
we will be looking at it I think that
then takes me into
um the putting
the motion for the officer's
recommendation for deferral
have I got that far yes sorry I'm having
a senior moment in that case can I have
um votes in favor please
that's carrot
right that concludes the public speaking
speaking for this meeting I will now
call upon the clerk to read out the
remaining planning applications if any
member wishes to reserve an application
will they please call out as the clerk
reads
thank you chair
uh the applications training are a02
unit 1 uh Blenheim close broadstairs and
AO3 Minster Maize and Grill 79 Mountain
Road Minster
okay
thank you can I have a proposer to move
that the applications that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the officer's recommendations
councilor Auburn and I'll go for
councilor bayford secondary
thank you
do members agree
and for the benefit of the public I will
call upon the clerk to read out the
applications that have been determined
okay again that's ao2 unit 1 lenham
close broadstairs and AO3 Minster Mason
Grill seven to nine Moncton Road Minster
thank you Jim
includes the business for the meeting
thank you for your attendance thank you
and good night